[Music]
April was jam-packed with news about all
the big games you're looking forward to
so we come through the headlines to
bring you the biggest stories that
really matter
hit that subscribe button and you'll get
every news video delivered right to you
because there's way more than just what
we're going to talk about here now let's
see what happened in April we call the
arms the splatoon of boxing when we
first played it and I'm going to stick
with that nickname the motion puncher
got the spotlight during Nintendo's
latest direct where we were introduced
to a new character the Robin fighter
minmin Nintendo also revealed new joy
Khan's with the hot neon yellow of the
arms logo plus battery adaptors to give
your controllers more juice on the go
you can get your hands on the game and
all those accessories on June 16th
[Music]
bandai namco published from software's
Dark Souls games so of course anything
it announces is going to get compared to
those and it doesn't help that the
teaser use the tagline prepare to dine
which is suspiciously similar to Dark
Souls prepare to die but now we know
that the game is code vain an action RPG
from the God Eater team all about
post-apocalyptic vampires hunting down
big monsters and draining their blood
for new powers typical vampire stuff
really we got some gritty screenshots
and bandai namco revealed that the game
is coming to quote major home consoles
in 2018 Dark Souls may not be getting
another sequel but the Last of Us
totally is the game is in its super
early stages so we've really only seen a
few photos of actors in the mocap studio
but one of those features Shannon
Woodward who plays Elsi in Westworld
she's not the only HBO talent working on
the game either it's being co-written by
West world writer Hayley growths we'll
find out what the ladies are cooking up
whenever we see more of the Last of Us
part 2
speaking of ps4 titles let's talk about
insomnia acts PlayStation exclusive
spider-man game we haven't seen or heard
much about it since the reveal trailer
but Marvel's Ryan Penn a ghost let the
games release window slip during a live
stream saying it be out this year and
then came insomniac response which said
that quote no official time frame has
been announced talk about having the web
pulled out from under you we did get our
first glimpse of the game at e3 2016 so
maybe we'll see more this year
let's talk about another Disney property
Star Wars Battlefront two's trailer
leaked then we got the official one then
we got a bunch more information the game
covers the full Star Wars saga with
playable characters from all three eras
the campaign stars an original female
soldier named I Denver CO and the story
is penned by one of the writers who
previously worked on spec ops the line
you can check out our lobby segment on
our impressions of the game so far but
you'll have to wait til November 17th to
play it let's return to Earth for a
different war the most famous one ever
in fact because Call of Duty is going
back to its roots with World War 2 the
official trailer shows off josh duhamel
sergeant wil Pearson though you'll take
control of a few different soldiers as
you battle through the European theater
with missions featuring d-day and the
Battle of the Bulge there's also a
separate co-op story featuring those fan
favorite zombies and a social space a la
Destiny's tower we're getting a proper
multiplayer reveal at e3 this June and
you'll be able to get your hands on the
full game on November 3rd and those are
the hottest stories for the most
anticipated games this month what else
are you looking forward to playing sound
off in the comments and don't forget to
subscribe to GameSpot for all the latest
on all the biggest games
[Music]